حماس ليست في صفك ليست في جانب
السلطة الفلسطينية
أنت في الضفة الغربية وهم
أيضا أه
يهددونك وأريد أن أعرف أنهم ليسوا بخير
لا أتفق مع ذلك لا أعتقد
حماس  يهددنا ما يهددنا هل
المستوطنون الإسرائيليون بخير ما
يهددنا هو الاحتلال الإسرائيلي ما
التهديد الذي يهددنا هو حقيقة أن
إسرائيل لا تتعلم من أخطائها
ومن تاريخها ونفس الشيء في
رأيي مثل
الإدارة الأمريكية الفاشلة  لكي نرى الأمور
بطريقة متساوية، حقيقة أنه
يُنظر إلينا كما لو كنا جميعًا إرهابيين،
أعني أن حماس ليست فقط هي التي
توصف بأنها إرهابية، فالكونغرس الأمريكي
يعتبر منظمة التحرير الفلسطينية بما في ذلك السيد
عباس إرهابية أيضًا، وبالتالي فإن القضية
هنا هي  هل نحن الفلسطينيون بشر متساوون
أم لا هل يُسمح لنا بمقاومة
الاحتلال كما يقول القانون الدولي أم
لا هل يحق لنا التمتع بالسلام
والأمن أيضًا أم لا إذا كان لإسرائيل
الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها هل
يحق للفلسطينيين أيضًا
الدفاع عن أنفسهم أم لا  ليس هذا هو
السؤال، وفي هذه اللحظة بالذات منذ
بداية هذا اليوم، قتلت إسرائيل
بالفعل 220 فلسطينيًا في غزة،
بما في ذلك مدنيون، وأصابت 1800
شخص. أنا أهتم بحياة
الجميع سواء كانوا فلسطينيين أو
إسرائيليين أو أي شخص آخر، لا أريد ذلك.
أي شخص يموت ولكني أقول أيضًا أنه يجب أن
نعامل كبشر على قدم المساواة
وهذا يعني أنه يحق لنا الحرية
وهذا يعني أنه يحق لنا إنهاء
الاحتلال. السبب الرئيسي لما
يجري هو الاحتلال المستمر هو
حقيقة أن العالم لديه  الصمت
عن الجرائم الإسرائيلية بحق الشعب الفلسطيني